[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rudy gobert
[Applaudissements]
ces belles mélodies
j'ai une soirée ce week end je devais
mettre une robe elle va tu vois on va
jouer à ce qu'on appelle la poubelle
c'est très simple celui qui perdra nous
d'eux devra le regarder dans les yeux
enfin moi dans tes yeux voient dans mes
pieds mais devra dire c'est toi le
patron d'accor avait dit devant tout le
monde et on enverra cette vidéo c'est au
lac tous les états unis d'accord vous
dis bien côté moi bah voila moi j'ai
touché un situe à tous
[Applaudissements]
oui je voulais dire devant toute la
france ce soir je n'ai qu'un seul patron
dans le monde
je dirais ton nom tous les jours jusqu'à
la fin de l'année dans tpm paie tous les
soirs avant de commencer l'émission se
dire et cette émission je la fais pour
mon maître rudy gobert c'est funky town
un truc fun qu'ils soient là ouais ouais
tu vas bruno mars tout quoi un sérieux
tu veux qu'on te
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
ça
vous dites notamment dans votre livre
parce que je voudrais être pour les
téléspecteurs tête des spectateurs qui
n'ont pas encore lu le livre que votre
père dès qu'il est sous l'emprise de
l'alcool ce qui est très fréquent le
moindre prétexte une note un regard ou
un geste suffit pour entraîner un
véritable déluge de gifles et de coups
dans le dos le plus souvent parfois sur
d'autres parties du corps moi je suis
allé sur le divan j'ai eu ce courage
parce qu'il faut le il faut du courage
pour le faire
j'ai eu du courage et j'ai travaillé
pour essayer d'aller mieux moi même pour
moi et pour les autres
pourquoi faut-il forcément par données
tirées annonçait sa flamme à gaz ion
pour avancer trêve la réponse de
d'isabelle et même par faire ce qu'ils
font pas j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
dents les signatures de livres dans les
salons un peu partout dans les
conférences que je peux te donner
je vois des gens qui viennent me parler
en disant bravo et tout mais moi je peux
pas ouais moi j'y arrive pas alors je
redis je comprends tout à fait mais
restez pas avec ça sur le sur l'estomac
ça va ça va vous vous vous auto dévorer
la france sur 100 français vous êtes
combien vous ne pas être satisfait quand
ils font zizi panpan tagada soir avec
leurs séries nouna 80% je peux pas être
partout
et aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale du pardon si vous nous
rejoignez http pardon dites nous si vous
aussi vous voulez pardonner ou vous
faire pardonner auprès de quelqu'un et
c'est vrai que bon enzo me suis plutôt
beaucoup occupé même si on a divorcé
assez tôt avec la vie je viens quand je
suis parti il avait trois ans mais sinon
il y avait neuf mois ses taux et ça donc
voilà donc voulait ce soir ses comptes
sur les véhicules
non mais c'est vrai parce que je rate
beaucoup de choses maintenant avec l'uja
ce qu'il est à la maison parce que ce
sport ensemble on se parle et c'est
super je te réveillant fait payer pas
l'air comme ça mais je raisonne voilà
pardon pardon à julien avant un simon je
vous aime
voilà c'est tout et je vais vous
demander pardon surtout pour un truc
c'est pour le chocolat
non
je te kiffe vous avez fait danse avec
les stars vous avez même terminé 6e il
ya un vrai dans ce qu'il ya c'est un
animal je pense qu'on devrait avoir une
petite relation entre eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce jour là
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ecopy ya moins comme vos caves là encore
à beyrouth de leurs mots c'est toujours
le premier donc pour balancer les
copains ya du monde
même quand on le fait soi même en garde
il ya une info qui est sorti c'est
l'american quoi tu es fan tutte encore
castaldi qui a son téléphone
c'était interdit
[Applaudissements]
pour toute dénonciation voiture contre
[Musique]
sa volonté
bachand a touché d'avion
[Applaudissements]
braga